[російською] Зі спогадів, люди,
що приїжджали до Нової Каховки, були вражені:
[російською] будиночки усі стояли біленькі,
навколо було багато зелені та квітів...
[російською] А орнаменти наче сяяли,
художники робили їх різної інтенсивності.
[російською] Фіолетові, лілові, зелені,
сині кольори були основою,
[російською] а зверху білий орнамент наче в'язь.
[російською] Багато хто каже,
що місто було наче в мереживі.
[російською] Так, у кам'яному мереживі, дуже гарно.
[російською] Те, що Григорій Довженко встиг
до серпня 1955 року зробити, те й залишилося.
[російською] За це його ще років десять
кляли останніми словами,
[російською] за «вицяцькування»
та надмірну витрату коштів та часу.
[російською] З його біографії ми дізналися,
що він ще «бойчукіст».
[російською] Він переїхав до Нової Каховки
і буквально зліпив місто.
[російською] Вклав у нього душу.
[російською] Бо усі ці 80 будиночків
[російською] прикрашені орнаментами,
які він зробив власноруч.
[російською] Вирізав з розчину,
склад якого сам вигадав та запатентував.
[російською] Що цікаво, на будинках
немає двох однакових орнаментів.
[російською] Це суто українські орнаменти.
[російською] На фотографіях видно,
як митці ходили у вишиванках під піджаками.
[російською] Вони будували нову Україну тоді.
[російською] Сподівалися, що так буде.
[російською] Вночі вони робили шаблон
у натуральну величину.
[російською] Вранці наносили на стіну розчин,
переносили на нього малюнок шаблону.
[російською] А потім вже різцями це все вирізбляли.
[російською] Титанічна робота!
[російською] Ми от зараз розчищаємо,
ведемо скребками по цим малюнкам
[російською] та уявляємо себе на місці тогочасних митців.
[російською] Дуже складна робота!
Зробили таке для міста.
[російською] Я жила у Новосибірську,
закінчила інститут і працювала там.
[російською] У 1986 році ми переїхали сюди.
Доля закинула.
[російською] Я навчалася у архітектурному
і ми вивчали, що Нова Каховка
[російською] увійшла до підручників з історії
як взірець міста, збудованного за єдиним планом.
[російською] Як Санкт-Петербург, як столиця Бразилії
місто Бразиліа. І Нова Каховка.
[російською] Ці три міста відзначалися у нашому підручнику
[російською] як унікальні, збудовані за єдиними планом.
[російською] Потім вже ми тут почали жити.
[російською] Мені поталанило одразу познайомитися
з Юрієм Костянтиновичем Насєдкіним,
[російською] першим архітектором Нової Каховки.
[російською] Він ось тут працював і розповідав мені,
як вони робили ті шаблони.
[російською] Цю всю історію ще він мені розповідав,
бо ми товаришували.
[російською] На жаль, він вже помер
і вся його сім'я теж похована.
[російською] [Після його розповіді] дуже захотілося
захистити це та зберегти.
[російською] Шкода, коли таку красу замінюють...
[російською] Там поруч один квартал забудований
[новобудовами] майже повністю — два будинки залишилося.
[російською] Ці будинки почали підпалювати.
[російською] Зносити, підпалювати, руйнувати.
[російською] А замість них будувати «коробки» з газобетону,
[російською] облицьовувати пінопластом, металопластиком.
[російською] Ця перлина з 1980-х років
була у списку історично значимих міст.
[російською] Тож чому тоді люди її оцінили,
а зараз ми забуваємо?
[російською] Ми за тиждень починаємо обходити будинки.
[російською] Обираємо, знайомимося з жителями,
попереджаємо: не лякайтеся!
[російською] Ми будемо під вікнами ходити,
[російською] ліси зведемо, будемо відновлювати.
[російською] Перша реакція:
от якби нам дах зробити, ремонт...
[російською] Кажемо: «Ні, то ви якось самі.
У нас студенти, діти, школярі, викладачі.
[російською] Усі в свій особистий час
будуть відновлювати орнаменти».
[російською] А потім жителі самі починають допомагати.
[російською] Пиріжками пригощають, чай приносять.
Пікніки проводимо.
[російською] Це вже третій будинок робимо.
[російською] А в першому будинку в перший же день
[російською] хлопець приніс відро ґрунтовки.
[російською] Мовляв, знадобиться вам фасадна ґрунтовка.
[російською] Потім ще розчин для ремонту приніс.
[російською] Ми вже навіть почали
деякі зруйновані елементи  відновлювати.
[російською] Вірніше, нас самостійно знайшов чоловік,
[російською] що вміє робити ці різблені орнаменти.
[російською] Подзвонив. Ми йому сказали,
що ми волонтери, безкоштовно це робимо.
[російською] Він каже: «Так-так!
Я дуже хочу приїжджати і відновлювати».
[російською] На цьому будинку
вже відновив велику частину.
Там листочок, там сердечко,
там соняшник, там ще щось...
Усі вони дуже різні.
[російською] Навіть обрамлення дуже різні.
[російською] Ми вже розповідали,
[російською] що спочатку розроблялися шаблони.
[російською] От здавалося, дві двері поруч,
[російською] чому б швиденько
не зробити два однакових шаблони?
[російською] Ні, одні двері такі, другі вже інші.
[російською] Навіть на одному фасаді елементи різні.
[російською] Із різними вкрапленнями.
[російською] Такого більше ніде нема.
Це неповторно.
[російською] Коли ми на туристичний конгрес знімали фільм,
внизу сиділа жінка, пила каву.
[російською] «Ой, ви мене не знімайте».
[російською] Почула мою розповідь і каже:
[російською] «Боже, я 18 років в цій будівлі
працюю і вперше це бачу».
[російською] Тобто в нас настільки «замилені» очі,
що ми не звертаємо увагу щодня, коли входимо в цей під'їзд.
[російською] А ми намагаємося зробити так,
щоб люди звернули увагу, в якій красі вони живуть.
[російською] І якщо громадські будівлі
та їхні фасади прикрашати — це звично,
[російською] то тут прикрашені входи навіть житлових будівль.
[російською] Ці будівлі були і залишилися житловими.
[російською] І кожен вхід до під'їзду прикрашений,
щоб людина, повертаючись з роботи,
[російською] не йшла вбита працею
до своєї вбогої квартири,
[російською] а поверталася додому як на свято,
в красивий будинок.
[російською] Ми знайшли родичів Григорія Довженка.
[російською] Після його смерті з майстерні був
вивезений ящик на дачу когось з родичів.
[російською] І от зараз вони його знайшли,
на ящику надпис «Нова Каховка».
[російською] А всередині щоденники,
світлини, рецепти розчину.
[російською] Тож в нас дуже великі сподівання,
що ми ще щось зможемо зробити.